jetzt gehen wir mal rüber zu einem
echten Mangel nämlich den Mangel an
Medikamenten Medikamente die dringend
benötigt werden es geht von fiebersäften
für Kinder aber auch zu Medikamenten für
Krebspatienten ich begrüße ganz herzlich
sie noch einmal von Enkel jung dass ich
hier sind uns einmal schildern wie es
aussieht was sie in ihren Apotheken
erleben denn man muss wirklich sagen man
ist erstaunt was dort eigentlich abgeht
dass wir in einer solchen Situation sind
und dass man sich fragen muss bekomme
ich eigentlich noch das was ich dringend
brauche also die Situation ist wirklich
im Moment dramatisch also wir haben
Lieferengpässe schon seit 2016 wobei wir
immer die Möglichkeit hatten
das zu regeln oder irgendwelche Lösung
für unsere Patienten zu finden
mittlerweile ist es so jeder zweite
Patient der zu mir in die Apotheke kommt
hat irgendein Medikament auf dem Rezept
was nicht lieferbar ist schwer lieferbar
oder sogar gar nicht lieferbar sei es
nur ein Paracetamol Ibuprofen Säfte für
die Kleinsten in unserem Lande eine
Mutter die mit im Notdienst steht und
ich kann ihr keine Paracetamolzäpfchen
geben und das Kind hat wo es Fieber ist
einfach dramatisch und ich frage mich
wirklich wo wir mit diesem Land noch
hinwollen wenn wir solche Banalitäten
die einfach vor 15 Jahren
selbstverständlich waren mittlerweile
nicht mehr liefern können
dramatische Lage die sie uns Schilder
nehmen Sie uns ein bisschen mit in Ihren
Alltag dort und welche Medikamente Sie
ein paar aufgezählt um welche Geister
besonders es geht los mit den Fieber und
schmerzhaften für Kinder wir haben
Engpässe im Bereich des Insulins bei
Diabetiker wir haben Engpässe bei
Herzmedikamenten dann gab es im Frühjahr
diesen Jahres das Problem mit dem
thermoxifen in dem Krebsmedikament für
Patienten wo selbst von oben die
Regierung so Einfluss genommen hat dass
nur kleinste Packung ausgeliefert werden
um diesen Liefering fast zu überbrücken
und ja wenn da nicht irgendwie von oben
von der Politik mal irgendwelche Weichen
gestellt werden wird es hier ein Land
der Nachfrage geben
gibt das Problem ist da und das will ich
ja auch überhaupt nicht negieren oder
wegdiskutieren die Frage ist wie lösen
wir jetzt das Problem und da sind wir
natürlich auch auf die Expertise von
Frau jung angewiesen ich glaube es sind
verschiedene Baustellen an denen wir
arbeiten müssen das eine ist das Thema
Rabattverträge das haben wir auch ja in
den vergangenen Jahren sehr bewusst
entschieden dass man gesagt hat
Krankenkassen müssen Rabattverträge
aushandeln um die eigenen Beiträge auch
stabil zu halten um verantwortlich mit
dem Geld der Beitragszahlen und
Beitragszahlung umzugehen und das führt
eben dazu dass oft auf Nebenprodukte
ausgewichen wird und die für mich auch
entscheidende Frage die noch gar nicht
so in der Diskussion in der Debatte ist
was für ein investitionsstandard Klima
haben wir eigentlich in Europa für große
Pharmaunternehmen wenn wir uns an die
letzten Jahre Debatten übergehen Technik
und anderes erinnern werden diese
Produkte eigentlich tatsächlich noch in
Europa entwickelt oder warum sind die in
andere Länder abgewandert wie wie Indien
ja also man kann nicht jedes Problem nur
mit Strompreis erklären also
es ist ja das ist auch ein Teil aber für
mich ist sehr für mich ist viel
entscheidender was für ein
Investitionsklima schaffe ich dann in
Deutschland in Europa das Produkte nicht
oft an den anderen Teilen der Welt
entwickelt werden sondern dass wir die
wieder zurückholen und dass wir hier vor
Ort oder in Europa auch eigene
Produktionsstätten haben die Produktion
hochfahren können und da hilft auch
nicht wenn man beispielsweise Corona bei
bei onetech sich zu Recht freut dass wir
in kürzester Zeit eine Impfstoff
entwickelt haben aber die nächste
Debatte dann aus deutscher Sicht direkt
ist wie schöpfig diese Gewinne ab und
die zweite Debatte hebe ich den
Patentschutz auf und wenn ich natürlich
diese Signale wenn ich diese Signale
reinsende in die in die
investitionslandschaften muss ich mich
nicht wundern dass Unternehmen ihre
standardpolitik so gestalten dass es
eben nicht mehr in Europa
diese Antwort genug war aber Herr gut
wir glaube ich auch noch mal an ja ich
meine die die Geschwindigkeit diese
gelobt haben bei den
Prozent Medikament ist sich so eine
Sache ich mache jetzt Recherche die
kommt am Donnerstag in der neuen
Weltwoche wo man einfach sieht dass die
sicherheitste eines völlig aus der Kraft
gesetzt worden sind nehmen das kann auch
nicht der der Weisheit letzter Schluss
sein und ich frage mich schon wo wir
eigentlich leben also wir sind hier in
einem hoch zivilisierten Land Schweiz
Deutschland vergleichbar
hochindustrialisiert dass das plötzlich
so ist dass wir nicht genug Energie
haben nicht genug Strom das wir nicht
mal mehr eine Medikamentenversorgung
gewährleisten können das ist schon sehr
penibel für unsere Politik und der Staat
muss nicht allzu vieles machen er muss
mir nicht vorschreiben mit der
coronazeit mit wie vielen Leuten im
Küchentisch sitzen soll er muss mir
nicht vorschreiben was ich für ein Auto
fahren darf und welches nicht aber
wirkliche grundlegende Dinge garantieren
Infrastruktur das sollte vielleicht noch
können und sonst sollte das meiner Sicht
die Finger ziemlich zurücknehmen aber da
kann ich natürlich ihre Sorge das kann
nicht sein dass man nicht mehr fähig ist
Medikamente der eigenen Bevölkerung zur
Verfügung zu verstehen wo leben wir die
eigentlich wir sind in der mitten in
Europa wir sind in Deutschland das nicht
möglich ist das ist schon eine traurige
Geschichte mit Verlauf also genau das
passiert wenn man einfach nur glaubt der
Staat soll sich raushalten und der Markt
soll mal machen denn die Sachen werden
ja aus China aus China und Indien
importiert
starten Staatswirtschaft hatten
ideologische Debatte dafür historische
das ist glaube ich etwa wie viel wie
lange war das hier entfernt von diesem
sende Standort vielleicht 0,8
Riesenschlangen wurden von Läden das
kennt die Leute noch in Ostdeutschland
aufgewachsen sind das meine Russland so
das ist ein Kuba heute noch so also
bitte sehr also wenn der Stadt die
Lösung sein soll für Mangel Probleme
dann gute Nacht ja das war jetzt einmal
die Ideologie Palette ist ja gut haben
die Geschichte nicht sind vielleicht
noch zu jung und das zu können
wahrscheinlich genau nee aber man muss
ja schauen wir haben auch bei vielen
anderen Produkten das gesehen wenn man
nur darauf guckt dass die Lieferketten
effizient sind das ist profitabel ist
das günstig ist dann lohnt sich keine
Lagerhaltung lohnt sich keine Puffer um
Lagerhaltung aber möglich zu machen das
ist teuer für ein Unternehmen muss man
das Anreizen ja wenn man Produktion in
Deutschland und Europa will nun dann
muss der Start da Anreize geben damit
sich das lohnt in China in Indien haben
die ganz andere Umwelt Standards allein
schon dadurch dass wir höhere
Umweltstandards haben ist es hier teurer
wenn wir strategisch strategische
Produkte
auserkoren wie zum Beispiel jetzt
Energie wie Medikamente wir haben noch
andere Rohstoffe sind ja auch sehr sehr
abhängig nun dann muss der Staat da
aktiv eingreifen und muss die den Markt
so regeln dass es sich in Deutschland
auch für Betriebe oder in Europa lohnt
das zu produzieren so wenn er das nicht
macht dann können wir nur sagen
hoffentlich kein wirtschaftsring mit
China weil wenn die Kilowattstunde habe
ich vier
centina bist du nicht mein Gast
Medikamente mehr liefert einmal ganz
andere Probleme genau also diese
Abhängigkeiten sind fatal vielleicht
auch junge Frauen
es liegt an mehreren Gründen also es ist
einmal natürlich dass der
Produktionsstandort Deutschland nicht
mehr gegeben ist die ganzen großen
Firmen denken Sie an sharing denken Sie
an Bayer denken Sie an BASF alle haben
irgendwo fusioniert oder ihr ihre
Produktion ins Ausland gestellt dann
kommt dazu der Druck der Krankenkassen
das alles billig billig billig sein soll
dadurch werden die Wirkstoffe wirklich
nur noch in Fernost hergestellt sie
haben das die Problematik der langen
lieferkettenwege sie haben die
Problematik ein Werk also dass die
Wirkstoffe wirklich nur noch in wenigen
Werken hergestellt werden so dass wenn
in einem
Industriestandort ein Fehler passiert so
wie damals bei den blutdruckmittelweise
Satan wo es zu Verunreinigung kam ja
dann bricht die ganze die ganze
Situation zusammen Ja damals hatten wir
dann die Möglichkeit die Patienten
umzustellen auf ein anderes Parlament
aber jetzt ist es ja nicht da und wenn
jemand in den Notdienst kommt und zu mir
sagt ich brauche Penicillin und ich habe
keine einzige Packung mehr dann frage
ich mich wirklich wo ist der Fehler wie
ist es denn also ich stelle mir vor Sie
stehen dort es kommt jemand und braucht
ein Medikament ganz dringend was sagen
sie irgendwas vor Augenblicken sie dann
und was sagen sie wir haben wir rotieren
rund um die Uhr sie müssen bedenken dass
die Apotheken täglich pro Stunde
mindestens eine Stunde damit beschäftigt
sind irgendwas zu bestellen direkt zu
bestellen irgendwelche
Nachfragen zu haben wir haben ein riesen
Mehraufwand in den Apotheken das muss
alles vom Personal gestemmt werden das
bekommen wir auch nicht bezahlt diesen
Mehraufwand nur die Dankbarkeit in den
Augen der Patienten wenn die zu mir in
die Apotheke kommen und sagen sie sind
die achte Apotheke und sie haben's wieso
haben sie es und die anderen nicht und
dann sage ich ja es ist alles nur eine
Organisation mittlerweile so wie früher
weißt du was machen sie das raten sie
den Menschen
wenn diese Organisation die Geräte auch
an ihre Grenzen wenn einfach das
Medikament nicht da ist und sie auch
sagen das kann ich jetzt nicht bestellen
und es ist morgen da was macht man dann
sagt man gehen sie ins Internet schauen
Sie mal um die Ecke da sind noch die
Kollegen also was für Möglichkeit die
letzte Lösung weil wenn Sie Ihre Rezept
zur Versandapotheke hinschicken dann
kommt irgendwie eine Meldung ja wir
können zur Zeit leider nicht liefern wir
melden uns wenn es wieder lieferbar ist
das sind dann die Patienten die als
erstes wieder bei mir vor der Tür stehen
das ist überhaupt keine Option weil
es ist wirklich die vor ortapotheke es
ist die persönliche ja Sorge die man für
den Patienten tagtäglich hat und auch
nach vorne trägt und das kriegt man ja
auch von den Patienten zurück und ähm
manche können noch warten paar Tage aber
bei manchen müssen halt sehen liefern
wir kleinere Mengen um das mehr zu
strecken dass sie hinkommen wenn es
wieder lieferbar ist der Fantasie sind
keine Grenzen gesetzt also sie versuchen
dann alles möglich zu machen ich stelle
mir das selber vor wir haben eben gerade
eingangs in der Sendung über den den
Saft für Kleinkinder gesprochen ich
meine ich habe drei Kinder wir brauchen
den ganzen Winter die ganze Zeit sind es
Infekte jetzt vor allem besonders auch
wieder was sagen sie wenn ich jetzt da
reinkomme mein Kind hat 40 Fieber zu
Hause versucht man mit wickeln irgendwie
das runter zu kühlen und sie haben es
nicht sie haben kein Fiebersaft würde
ich glaube ich bei ihnen Tränen
ausbrechen das glaube ich gerne also wir
sind Gott sei Dank bevorratet wir haben
also wir bekommen immer wieder was aber
es ist halt alles nur noch häppchenweise
und nur auf Nachfrage ich meine wenn ein
großer Lieferant von uns und die gesamte
Winter Bevorratung absagt einen Monat
vor bevor der Winter losgeht dann bricht
da natürlich auch bei uns alles zusammen
dann versuchen wir das irgendwo zu
ersetzen durch andere Firmen und und
aber es ist halt letztendlich wenn Sie
das Beispiel Paracetamol Saft nehmen von
den Krankenkassen wird ein Bruchteil
bezahlt ich weiß gar nicht wie viel der
jetzt kostet 2,03 Uhr da frage ich mich
davon muss die Verpackung bezahlt werden
der Weg die Produktion
der Rohstoff wir machen uns selber
kaputt mit diesem ganzen Preis nach
unten drücken und ganz ehrlich wir
müssen uns auch mal sehen die
Arzneimittelausgaben sind
1,98 Prozent der ganzen
Gesundheitsausgaben im ganzen Land
unterfrage ich mich wofür brauchen wir
fast 100 Krankenkassen
wo mir den Chef bezahlen diese Kriterien
und und und ich glaube da müsste man
auch erstmal anfangen und vielleicht da
eine Kostenreduktion einführen indem man
die ein bisschen einschmelzt die machen
ja vor allem auch alle Werbung
gegeneinander also das macht ja macht ja
auch gar keinen Sinn das ist gar kein
Markt wo man richtigen Wettbewerb hat
anderen Punkt den ich am Anfang voll der
gut wenn Sie das jetzt hören Kostendruck
und alles noch rausquetschen das ist ja
das was der Markt
verursacht wenn man freien Wettbewerb
sozusagen
reguliert das steht natürlich nicht wir
haben den Bereich der obligatorischen
Krankenversicherung gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben ist was man anbieten muss
und da ist kein richtiger Wettbewerb
Wettbewerbs nur im privaten Versicherten
Bereich möglich was darüber hinausgeht
und das Gesundheitssystem ist ganz ein
schlechtes Beispiel für einen freien
Markt weil es eben wie kaum ein anderes
überreguliert ist